- For a Black woman to be
selected to serve on the Supreme
- Victorine Bonsange-Basia
et Linda Pascaline Nizeyimana,
à l'Université de Montréal,
écoutent avec admirationKetanji,
la première femme noireir juge e
des États-Unis.
- C'est tellement une fierté
de voir tée au plutée au plutéet
tribunal du pays!
- C'est vraiment une source
- The "yays" are 53 the "nays"
are 47; and this nominationis c.
- Cette page d'histoire qui
s'écrit au sud de la frontière
canadienne aide Victorine à
chasser ressent au sein
de la faculté de droit.
VICTORINE BONSANGE-BASIA, Asso.
étudiants noirs enonne qui eonnt
comme toi, qui est nominée
à la Come, t'es comme :
OK, je mérite d'être là,
je mérite d'être ici et
je mérit le monde. le monde. le.
- Les accomplissements de
Brown Jackson inspirent
aussi les futures avocates
à élargir leurs horizons
LINDA PALINDA PALINDA PALINDA Po
étudiants noirs en droit, UdeM
- Est-ce que ça me tente
de devenir juge? Est-ce que
c'est possible pour moi
que c'est des questions que,
au départ, j'avais pas dans
ma tête parce que j'osais pas
nécessairement penser à ça,
mais maintenant que
c'est possible, j'ose avoir
ces pensées-là.
- Aucune femme noire n'a brisést
des provinces canadiennes ne
sont pas en mesure de confirmer
leur nombre dans leur tribunaux
respectifs.Hélène Dubé
est devenue le mois dernier la
deuxièoire juge nommée
à la Cour supérieure du Québec,
après sa collègue Guylène Beaugé
- C'est de la fierté,
beaucoup de bonheur.
femme noire avocate nommée
associée dans un grand cabinet
nationale au Québec, croit que
la magistrature doit refléter
la population.
Black Lawyer Association
- Il faut cette diversité
de points de vue pour pouvoir
rendre une justice qui est
perçue comme étant
- Patricia Fourcand souhaite
fasse sentir son influence.
- Même si ses positions ne sont
pas majoritaires, je pense
des dissidences qui vont faire,
je l'espère, vont faire évoluer
le droit, la cause de
la diversité, de l'antiracisme.
- Ici comme aux États-Unis,
Ketanji Brown Jackson pourra
compter sur l'appui symbolique
de femmes qu'elle a inspirées.
Ici Valérie-Micaela Bain,
Radio-C